le han apodado el maestro de las
marionetas el británico robert henri
free garde está huyendo de la policía
francesa después de golpear a dos
agentes durante una redada en el centro
del país el estafador condenado vivía
aquí en este pequeño pueblo francés al
que se trasladó después de pasar cuatro
años en la cárcel por engaño y secuestro
robando más de un millón de libras a
múltiples víctimas fue objeto de un
documental de netflix a principios de
este año en el que los hijos de una
mujer que se cree que su actual pareja
decían que estaba desaparecida después
de conocerle los vecinos dijeron que la
pareja de angie fregado vivía en pésimas
condiciones y que rara vez se le veía
fuera yo
siempre me sorprendió mucho la situación
de esta mujer en este momento llevaba
unos cinco años allí que nosotros no
salía nunca de su casa vivía en
condiciones extrañas o remotos e intente
alertar a las autoridades pero sin mucho
éxito me convocó si se cree que ha
regresado recientemente al reino unido
mientras la policía busca a freeman que
podría enfrentarse a cargos de intento
de asesinato